معادله انتخابيه معقده فرضها استاذ
الفيزياء والكيمياء محرم انجا على
المعارضه التركيه زعيم حزب البلد الخطيب
والمفوه القادر على كسب تعاطف وتاييد
الناخبين بات مرشحا رئاسيا بعد نجاحه في
جمع مئه الف توقيع لدخول السباق الانتخابي
لدى السيد محرم انجا فرصه في هذه
الانتخابات قبل شهرين كانت نسبته دون
الواحد بالمئه لكن مؤخرا نرى في
الاستطلاعات ان نسبه زادت الى نحو 5% وفي
اخر اسبوع وصل الرقم الى 7% وفي بعض
التقديرات راينا ان النسبه تتجاوزت 10%
اذا تحالف الامه المعارض امام تحدي جديد
بعد ازمه داخليه انتهت بترشيح كمالك
لمنافسه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في
انتخابات الرابعه عشر من ماي القادم فان
جاء المنشق عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري بعد
خلافه مع كلجدار اوغلو وتاسيسه حزب البلد
يستهدف شريحه من ناخب تحالف الامه
الرافدين لترشيحك الجدار اوغلو اضافه لفئه
الشباب
خلال فتره جمع توقيعات كان هناك دعم واضح
واستثنائي للسيد محرم انجا من فئه الشباب
لاحظنا توجه عدد كبير من الشباب الذين
سينتخبون لاول مره الى فروعنا وتقديمهم
طلبات الانضمام لحزبنا
حسين الذي سينتخب للمره الاولى جاء الى
احد فروع المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات في
اسطنبول واختار دعم انجاه الذي يجد فيه
الحل لمعضله الاقتصاد
انا ادعم السيد محرم ان جاء لانه سيعمل
على تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي للبلد كون
الذين سبقوه لم يتمكنوا من اصلاح الوضع
انا اثق به لانه سيحسن الوضع في البلاد
خشيه تفتت اصوات المعارضه ناشد عدد من
النواب السابقين من حزب الشعب الجمهوري
انجا بالانسحاب ويبدو ان ثمن عدوله عن
قراره في حال قرر التنازل سيكون باهظا جدا
على كل جدار اوغلو وتحالف الامه
المطالبه حينها بتقديم تنازلات كبيره
لانجاح مقابل الانسحاب
نظريا يعد الرئيس اردوغان اكبر المستفيدين
من ترشح محرم انجا منافسه السابق في
انتخابات 2018 لكن جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات قد تدفع انجاب لدعمك الجدار
اوغلو ضد
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول